[Music]
there's a primal urge in all of us to
explore
in the closing shot of for all mankind's
second season we got our first glimpse
of 1995
and a human walking on the surface of
mars in the first trailer for season
three there's a whole lot of mars action
with a three-way race to get there first
hey guys pete here today i'm going to
break down that season 3 trailer which
looks pretty amazing as is the show's
custom we will be moving forward in time
we left things in 1983 after danny and
stephen decided to go through with
apollo soyuz and ed decided to take down
sea dragon himself it looks like the
mars landing will happen in 1995 but the
season picks up in 1992
giving us time to see how that race
develops the trailer opens with dany
saying that there's a primal urge in all
of us to explore we see a shot of her on
the u.s mission coupled with a shot of
ed and civilian clothes on what looks
like this large ship that has a rotating
wheel to create artificial gravity this
is also known as a von braun wheel
because werner who you'll remember from
season one used this idea as part of a
concept ship he came up with for a trip
to mars in the 1950s in our timeline in
an interview with ew the show's creators
mentioned a friendly competition between
danny and ed to see who might get to
command the mission to mars it makes
sense then to open the trailer with
these two characters
and based on what we see danny wins that
as mentioned we do see her on the
mission and on this one shot you can see
that she's wearing the mission badge
nasa's ship is called the sojourner one
there's a shot of it approaching the red
planet and i'm guessing this first shot
is also it taking off from the surface
of the moon we also get a look at the
soviet ship during its terrestrial
launch it's called mars 94 which is
taken from an actual proposal that they
made to visit mars in 1994 but of course
in our timeline the soviet union had
been dissolved by that year as has
become standard for this show we don't
see much from the soviet perspective in
this trailer it's interesting that in
the alternate timeline there are still
two competing super powers we did find
out in the opening montage of season two
that they avoided getting bogged down
fighting in afghanistan and it's
possible the chernobyl disaster was
averted in the same way as we know the
three-mile island was in this timeline
remember the catalyst for the show is
that the soviets beat the us to land the
first man on the moon because of that
the space race continued and you see
several indications in this trailer that
nasa is determined to get to mars first
and get a win in one shot you see the
now short-haired margot addressing her
staff in a meeting saying we're not
going to come in second place again to
anyone that last part hints at the third
party that's entered the race in the
years that have passed since season two
my assumption is this large ship in
orbit above earth was built by a private
company called helios aerospace you see
their ceo dev isa on tv talking about
disagreeing with the idea that private
citizens don't belong in space their
ship is called phoenix and my guess is
that ed left nasa after losing the
competition to command sojourner and is
now in charge of helios's mission it
also looks like kelly has followed in
her father's footsteps you see her on a
ship or maybe in a base saying we're
talking about discovering life on
another planet it will change our
concept of who we are where we're going
there's another shot with ed and it
looks like she's saying this to him and
the reason why i thought it might be on
the surface is that you see a russian
suit hanging behind him
the helios suits appear to be blue and
there are some shots of them on mars in
one they're unloading what almost looks
like a rover but the markings say hab1
perhaps that is what they're in in the
previous shots and it can be moved
around or at least unloaded on wheels
you hear the helios ceo say that being
first is what it's all about with what
margot said earlier it looks like both
sides could be in a position to push
things and if ed is the commander of
phoenix then it makes sense that he
would be pushing since he knows what
it's like to miss out on the opportunity
to be first from way back on apollo 10
when he followed his mission instead of
touching down on the moon and being the
first person to do so this could be his
chance to erase that what if memory it
looks like things will go wrong when
they get there you hear that massive
dust storms have obscured both landing
sites this makes it sound like it comes
down to helios and nasa if there are
only two but there are these other shots
of cosmonauts preparing as well we know
they will get there there are several
shots of landers and plenty of activity
on the surface so the drama will be and
who is the first to land i guess also
finding the water seems to be an issue
at first at least you hear the ceo
asking where it is
later ed is talking to kelly about a
resource that can support large-scale
human colonization it's not clear from
the trailer what he's talking about and
i'm no expert here but a google search
will tell you that there are ample
resources that could be useful for
colonization available on mars so much
so that it seems like most strategies to
set up a permanent settlement would
involve sending automated ships ahead of
any human missions to get things set up
ahead of time not sure if they already
did that or if that will have anything
to do with their conversation but i did
go down a rabbit hole reading about it
so i thought i would mention it part of
what's interesting about ed working for
the private firm is that they may be
actively poaching people from nasa we do
have several shots of mission control
where it looks like bill aka peanut has
finally made it to flight director and
it's possible that alita will as well
because she's in that same position we
see margot molly and even ellen at jsc
so i don't know who that leaves to be on
ed's side over at helios there's a shot
of molly with a white cane so i'm
guessing she's blind now but it doesn't
appear to be holding her back from
working at nasa there is a shot of
helios mission control and i don't
notice any familiar faces there's a shot
of karen that might be there and her
going into private space travel with sam
was a popular theory but she could also
be there because of ed and kelly since
we don't know anything about where deb
iesa came from it's hard to put things
together in that part of the story there
are a lot of unknowns danny appears to
be an astronaut now too and in this one
shot of him that looks like it's at jsc
you can't miss that he has a wedding
ring on i looked at the cast list on
imdb and noticed an amber stevens who i
suppose is his wife and i guess that
means nine years later he's moved on
from his obsession with karen after her
midlife crisis situation that happened
there at the end of season two
whether the baldwin stayed together will
be one of the answers we'll get in
season three i don't see anything in
this trailer that would indicate if they
did one way or the other what looks like
one of the big space sequences we'll get
early in the season is some kind of an
issue on the phoenix while it's still in
earth's orbit there's a cable that's
broken loose and two astronauts in grey
suits getting knocked off the ring
originally i thought this was during
construction but there's this shot of
the interior where you see people
falling over that's probably related to
that i don't really know there are
several shots of civilians walking
around in the ring section and none of
anything that looks like a journey to
mars
so maybe helios has built this and is
showing it off before sending it to the
red planet a couple of shots that are
probably related to this accident have
an astronaut in a similar gray suit
hanging near a thruster and opening a
panel there's another one that has what
i guess is the same cable still whipping
around and this almost looks like danny
to me that doesn't seem right since he
was at nasa so i guess we'll have to
wait and see what's going on here it
does look like there'll be plenty of
action there are quite a few shots of
things looking hectic in space and the
last big thing that stands out is that
it looks like ellen has moved into
politics there's a shot of her running
for senate in 86 and i guess it must be
a flashback or part of the opening
montage if they do that again and with
the confetti falling from above it looks
like she probably won her race this
could be interesting considering there
would be presidential elections in 1992
and 96. if the season opens in 92 and
they get to mars in 95 then president
ellen wilson might happen this season it
all looks pretty exciting you see signs
that technology continues to outpace our
timeline there are flat screen displays
everywhere i'm curious to see how some
of those final notes of season two
affected things in the time between that
we didn't see and i think that's a good
place to leave things let me know in the
comments what you think about this
trailer what i missed and what you
thought i got right and what i got wrong
and what you're hoping to see please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon